no one likes getting locked out of
things homes computers heaven however
some destiny players are reporting a bug
that gets them locked out of the
all-important tower however the bug is
also revealing a bunch of hidden destiny
dlc info I'm step forward and together
let's investigate the leak on this GS
news update when the bug occurs the map
shows several new locked areas some of
which have already been announced as DLC
the events include new story missions
strikes and raids all of which take
place on the celestial bodies that are
already included in the main game you
can see the full list on reddit having
been deconstructed by user killed by
dice however bungees david deejay day
get responded to the leak saying studios
next destiny expansion packs are not
finished meaning that the leak might not
offer a clear picture of what to expect
we noticed that you notice that we
already have plans for upcoming content
packs in destiny we do they have
activity names which may or may not
change and we have a really good idea
what they're going to contain they even
have placeholder nodes in the director
as you've already discovered but neither
of the expansion packs we've announced
are finished Destiny's first piece of
DLC the dark below is scheduled to land
sometime in December but as DJ said any
of the content shown in the leak could
be subject to change before that time or
not be there at all or it could all be
in another loot cave so do the leaked
missions and raids fill you with
overwhelming hope or crippling fear for
destiny what's your favorite gain
improving bug let me know somewhere in
the comments box below and for all the
linky bugs updates stay tuned to
gamespot